GREG IVANOV: So sort of
the goal of this session
is to get into the nitty
gritty, a little bit, of what it
actually means to
develop for VR.
So we've got a fascinating
selection of panelists
to take us through some of the
foundational aspects of what
it's like to actually
develop for VR.
We've got Peter from
Resolution Games, who's
going to talk about what it's
like to develop for a medium
where a user has
no expectations.
Bradley from BBC
is going to talk
about transitioning the
brand and keeping the brand
integrity into a new medium.
And then Kay from
ARTE is going to talk
about this
much-talked-about dichotomy
or interrelation between linear
and interactive experiences.
So come on up, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
And Peter, over to you
with the first lightning
talk that you're going
to take us through.
PETER STAHL: So I'm
going to look over there.
OK.
Hi, I'm Peter.
And I work at Resolution Games.
We're based in
Stockholm, Sweden.
And when we develop games
in virtual reality now,
we like to start in
reality, and then
try to bring the things that
are interesting into fantastic.
An example of that
is one of our games.
We had the fortune as to
be one of the launching
titles for Daydream.
And it's called "Wonderglade."
And it's basically
doing something
familiar in an
unfamiliar context.
So the example
from "Wonderglade,"
that is that shooting hoops.
Throwing a basketball
is very familiar.
And you can't trick the brain.
You've got to make
it feel like you're
throwing that basketball.
But you're doing it on the moon.
That's kind of unfamiliar.
So that's what we found
really interesting
and what the players
like the most.
GREG IVANOV: Awesome.
Bradley?
BRADLEY CROOKS:
Right, thank you.
I'm Bradley from BBC Worldwide.
So sometimes when a new kind
of technology comes along,
it's really tempting to
kind of get caught up
in what that technology
can do for you
and maybe to forget
some of the things that
make your brand what it is.
And you should be thinking
about the things that
make your brand what it is.
And they might be as
practical as the kind
of logos that you use or
the color schemes that you
use and so on.
But beyond that, there
should be other things
in terms of kind of like the
brand value, so the things
that represent your brand
at a very high level.
And really, when you're
taking your brand
into a new media
like VR, you need
to be rigorously applying those
kind of checks and processes
when you sort of take your
brand into a new medium.
And to give you an example,
we're doing a lot of work
at the moment with
our BBC Earth brand.
It's natural history content.
Some of you might be
familiar with this.
One of the last
things that we did
was called "Planet Earth 2."
There's a scene in that where
there's iguanas versus snakes.
We call these kind
of iconic scenes.
And these are something that
we tend to have, always,
when we put out
our kind of what we
call landmark series each year.
But really, this is
just underpinning
the kind of brand
values that make up
what BBC Earth is all about.
Those brand values are
things like the editorial
and scientific rigor.
We make sure that everything
we do, in whatever medium,
is rigorous in terms of its
application of the science
that we apply.
Probably the biggest
and most important
thing is also storytelling.
That's something in
everything that we do.
And if you think about it, that
iguanas versus snakes example
is a good example of
storytelling, right?
And that's something that
we want to carry through
into all of the media that
we do and all the content
that we produce.
So that's something that
we're thinking about when
we're creating VR experiences.
And finally, and
this is easy with VR,
we're thinking about innovation.
So that doesn't
necessarily come to mind
when you're thinking about
BBC natural history content,
but actually, every time
a new series comes out,
we're using new technology.
We're either using new
cameras or using drones
to take pictures, or we're using
new submersible techniques.
And again, we want to carry
through that kind of brand
value into VR.
So the types of things, the
types of kind of content
that we're delivering, the
way in which people interact,
and so on, we want
to innovate with.
GREG IVANOV: Thank you.
Kay?
KAY MESEBERG: Yep.
Yeah, that's me.
Kay from ARTE.
Our trigger for VR
at ARTE was really
that it's something-- it's a
medium which attracts interest
of all generations.
I mean, from kids
to grandparents,
everybody is attracted by VR
and is fascinated by that.
But to get and to keep this
interest for VR productions--
we started now in 2014, I
think, with the first one--
a key question is
really the interface
and the accessibility.
So interacting in VR should
be close to human behavior,
as easy as breathing
or drinking water.
It should be really easy
to seamlessly get into VR,
and also the same for augmented
reality for some projects
we're working on.
I would like to show you two
examples how we distinguish
the things a bit.
I mean, one is that we do a lot
more linear productions based
on 360 video, but also added
with metadata, which as,
for instance, "Dolphin
Man," a series,
a VR series we just published.
So we take people to
exceptional places
and to give access to
exceptional places.
In this example,
you can really dive
with free divers, more than
five meters, 10, 20 meters,
50 meters down in the ocean.
You can swim with
dolphins and stuff
like that, and sperm whales.
So it's something exceptional.
You cannot live like
that out of the box.
And the second one is more
interactive experiences,
but also with the same
goal to be really seamless
in terms of navigation.
That's "Notes On Blindness."
Its a story of a British
man who lost sight,
and he did an audio
journal about it.
And the fascinating thing
with this audio journal
is that it really explains
extremely interesting what
happens to him.
So we did a VR experience with
our French partners about it.
And its extremely interesting.
After you saw it, you understand
what it means to lose sight.
And the interactive
part in that is just
based on the way you move, with
sound, with different things
like that.
You don't need to click
on something or anything.
Its just seamless into
the whole experience.
So these are the goals
we are working on.
And we're working on more in VR.
GREG IVANOV: Cool.
Thank you.
So super amazing to have
such a wide cross-section
of developers in the room.
And I think probably, let's
make this practical, right?
So we've got developers
here who are perhaps
thinking of getting into VR.
And with that, you know,
what would be the number one
piece of advice that you'd
give to someone who is thinking
of starting out in VR today?
Bradley, what would you say?
BRADLEY CROOKS: It's
a good question.
I think, and I've always sort
of said, go in with your eyes
open.
Quite literally, maybe.
You know, it's not an
easy kind of medium
to develop for it first.
There's quite a
steep learning curve.
Our first foray
into it, we sort of
thought, oh, this will
be relatively easy.
We'll sort of crack a couple
of experiences out there
and get them through submission.
And everything took
three times as long,
cost three times as much,
as we were expecting.
And actually, to kind
of go back to my point
I was making before, to
uphold the things that
are important to us
about our brands,
like the quality of
the output and so on,
actually took a
significant amount of time.
And I think it's
only really just now
that we've really
kind of learned
how to approach that
properly and, you know,
do things in the right way.
And that will be a sort of
continuing learning process
as new tech comes out and so on.
GREG IVANOV: So what
would you say, then,
in that sense to someone's who's
just thinking of starting out?
Or any of you guys that
have a good piece of wisdom
in terms of the first
thing to think about
or the first potential
failure that you
have to think about in
terms of developing for VR?
PETER STAHL: I would
say, start with the core.
Start simple.
One of my developers usually
says, throw crap on the wall
and see what sticks.
You've got to try.
You've got to try
a lot of things,
because it's a moving platform.
It's a moving target
that you're aiming for.
So you just try, try, try, try.
And come back to the things
that just feels good.
BRADLEY CROOKS: I think knowing
what your objectives are.
You know, you have an end goal.
What are you actually
trying to achieve with this?
Are you trying to do this from
a commercial point of view?
Are you trying to do it
from a brand point of view?
What are your objectives?
And that's probably true
of most ventures, right?
But I think it's particularly
true with something
which combines a lot of
creativity and a lot of tech.
So it is, like you say, it's
kind of a moving target.
And you know, sometimes
it moves whilst you're
developing for it, right?
So yeah, I mean, I
think it's good to have
an end goal in mind.
KAY MESEBERG: I think
it's also extremely
interesting and important
to work on ideas, in the way
that you have an idea, and you
can put it in one sentence,
and you pitch to someone,
and it makes click.
And I think that's a key
factor in the beginning.
And then you add the tech to it.
But if you have this
kind of basic idea
which really convince
people, and it convince,
you know, a little boy of
five years or a granny of 90,
then you think you know
that you are really
working on something
interesting and great
and which can be really great.
And then you add the tech.
You add the different ways of
sound, of cameras, of unity,
whatever.
You decide what you
want to use for it.
And that's, I
think, a key factor.
GREG IVANOV: That's great.
I think one interesting
mantra that we all
know in a mobile world is
fail cheap and fail fast.
And I just want to
kind of drill down
on that a little bit
in the context of this
question as well.
It kind of works in
mobile pretty well.
You can fail cheap
and fail fast.
With VR and the costs and
the know-how associated
with developing for VR, that's
presumably a lot harder to do.
So how do you--
do you still apply
the same method?
Or do you just not, and you
see this as an investment
of a different kind?
And you have to
convince, perhaps,
your leadership that this is
just the way it has to be?
Peter, do you have
a take on that?
PETER STAHL: Yeah, I guess they
must throw crap on the wall
and see what sticks.
Yeah, it does apply,
I think, partially.
I think you have
to make a few bets.
I think you've got to pick a
few things that you actually
believe is going to happen.
Like for example, we
believe that the cords in VR
are going to go away.
You're going to be
moving around a lot more.
There's a lot of
those examples where
you got to go, that we really
believe is going to happen,
because, again, it's
a moving platform.
It does apply in the
sense that if you've
got to do something
that you are very
unsure of if it's going to be
successful or not, then yeah.
Fail fast.
KAY MESEBERG: I think
it's also important to be
flexible in a way
that you can port
your experience with
different other platforms,
to do real life experiences in
cinemas, to bring it on mobile,
to bring it on different
headsets and stuff like that.
I mean, that can really
trigger the evolution.
And it can help
that with porting,
you redefine the
things you're doing.
So I think it's
really amazing to see
that things are working great on
Daydream, but also on Android.
But on Android, they are known
as, also, some other headsets
and stuff like that.
But still, we can show
it in planetariums,
in screens which
are 30 meters large.
And you can watch it
together with 300 people
in a cinema-like setting.
So I think that's really
the interesting, great thing
with VR today, that you are
on a step into something new,
and everybody's trying out.
And then as many as
different ways you try out,
and I think you will succeed
in the one or the other.
GREG IVANOV: By
the way, if anyone
has a question in the audience,
feel free to raise your hand,
and we'll give you
a mic or something.
Or just ask.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GREG IVANOV: Just over there.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm Martin.
I'm in company for [INAUDIBLE].
We have a division
called [INAUDIBLE]..
And we have already more
than 3,000 VR videos
in our platform.
[INAUDIBLE] reaching
5,000 in a few months.
And we still have the
struggle, I would say,
like the classical
TV or video approach,
to have the passive watching
of the videos in 360
or virtual reality content
comparing to active.
So what is your point of
view of to bring more--
if it's the way to bring more
active interaction with video,
or--?
We are now in Android platform,
with a new generation on Oculus
will be ready in a few weeks.
And then, we have some
[INAUDIBLE] VR [INAUDIBLE]
in our own channel.
So what is your
approach to bring
more customers [INAUDIBLE]
to show this, see the content
and to be entertained
by the content,
or to go more to interact
with the content in VR world?
Thank you.
BRADLEY CROOKS: Yeah,
I mean, I think that--
it's an interesting question,
because different parts
of the BBC are doing
different things.
We're doing kind of--
people who are interested
in sort of live streaming
e-sports through VR and so on.
There's a big divide, I
think, between 360 content
and real-time content.
And you know, obviously
there's a certain amount
that you can do to
overlay one or the other.
I think in everything
you create, again,
thinking of what
the end goal is,
you need to be adding value.
And I think one of the
problems that VR has had is--
and it's the same with most kind
of new techs-- is people go,
wow, there's this
amazing new thing.
Let's build some stuff for it.
Not necessarily thinking
if this is something
that the audience
actually wants.
And I think you have to be
thinking, in any product
development, you know,
who's my audience?
What do they need?
And what can I offer them?
And if you can answer
those three things,
and that allows you to come
up with a product which
is going to make their life
easier or more entertaining
or whatever it is, then I
think you'll be successful.
But I think just doing
something because you
hope the market will develop,
I think that's risky.
Very risky.
So I think it's really key to
be thinking of your consumer
always, what's going
to be good for them.
If that answers your question.
GREG IVANOV: Kay, you probably
have a point of view on that,
since you spoke about
linear and interactive.
KAY MESEBERG: I think the
real interactive is still
based on mobile.
It's based on the VR headsets.
And we see grow, that there
are more and more headsets
on the market.
So the market is getting
bigger and bigger.
Still, with linear,
you have the advantage
that you can really
make access to people
who don't have a
headset but who are
familiar with video in general.
So they understand it like that.
And I think if you create out
of that great experiences, that
can be a bit more
convincing just
to understand this
new evolutionary step
into computing and this kind
of new platform, this kind
of new interactive
realities coming up there.
And it's a really good
tool, like a technology
that's kind of doing the
bridge between the two.
And that's why we
shouldn't underestimate,
really, linear-based videos.
GREG IVANOV: Yeah, and I think,
[INAUDIBLE] from the Daydream
side, we've seen that actually
the most-used app on Daydream
was YouTube.
So linear 360 video
is playing a big part.
And I don't think we want to
say that 360 or linear video
is some kind of a step towards
the ultimate goal, which
is interactive.
It's not.
I think, as Bradley
mentioned, it's
really about what you're
trying to achieve.
And sometimes 360 video is
exactly the right format.
And also, it's often
cheaper to produce.
So that's a good thing, too.
I think there was another
question from a gentleman here?
AUDIENCE: Hi, hello.
I'm Antoine.
I work at [INAUDIBLE].
We're a language learning app.
And we've just built
a VR experience
for another platform.
And one of my questions
is around replayability,
because obviously, those
experiences are quite finite.
And I guess, as all
platforms, we'll
be looking at retention
as a key metric.
So how do you make
sure, you know,
that the headset
just doesn't become
one thing that's just left
in the cupboards out of view,
and people come back to
your experiences over time?
PETER STAHL: I would
start by saying--
sorry.
As I said, placing bets
before in what you believe
will happen in time to come.
I personally believe that
we're not quite there yet.
There's a cap.
There's an experience
cap, which is--
that's sad, but
it's going to come.
Technology is moving
extremely fast.
And I think, yeah, you've got to
be there when it goes relevant.
I think you've got to be ready
when putting that thing on
and whatever happens in that
reality feels relevant to you.
And also, you've got
to place those bets
on what you believe is relevant
to your target audience.
For example, a group
of young people
might want to meet up and
play their favorite game
and so forth.
And you might want to meet
with your son or your daughter
across the world.
Different groups.
BRADLEY CROOKS:
Yeah, I mean, there's
some BBC research, actually,
that was done recently
about little kind of barriers.
You might have seen it.
It's really interesting.
And one of the biggest
barriers is that people
lose their headsets.
So you know, it's
a different thing
to kind of switch on your TV and
interact with content that way,
to actually go and
find your headset,
put it on, go through the
process of booting it up,
and so on.
And the research
found that that was
one of the most difficult
things about VR,
is that people tend to do things
in order of how easy they are.
And VR comes fairly
low down the list.
And that's one
reason why I think it
has to have that added value.
You know, it has to be
something that people
are going to kind of want
as a destination to go to.
But I do think, as well-- we
were just talking about this
before--
that we are in the really
early stages of VR.
There's been a huge
amount of noise about it.
And people are saying,
it's not going to work,
and people aren't
investing in it and so on.
It's incredibly unfair,
because it's only
really been in its current form
around for 18 months to two
years.
If you look at the mobile
market, which has been around
for a long, long time,
much of the sophistication
about retention and
so on is only really
now kind of coming to the fore.
And you look at the way
that mobile companies sort
of reengage people and
so on, that's years
of R&D and investment and tying
into social channels and so on.
And I think VR and AR will
have that eventually as well.
And that will help with
retention and getting
people to come back
in and discoverability
and all those things.
KAY MESEBERG: Yeah, it's
an interesting comparison
to mobile, because,
actually, the first mobile
or smartphones, they came to
market in the '90s, something
like that.
But it made boom in the
2000s, with Android,
with iOS and stuff like that.
So there was quite a big period
In between the first market
phones, like the Nokia back in
the days and stuff like that.
And I think that seeing VR
moving today, since, like,
2014, since we do
it, it's really fast.
I think I'm quite surprised
in different levels,
I mean, in adoption
and stuff like that.
But I think, also, that the
midterm or the next goal
will be that it's kind of
something which is where people
ask for experiences,
but not because it's
VR, because they ask that they
heard something is really great
and they want to play it,
or they want to see it,
or whatever.
I think that will be the
next goal for the next year.
GREG IVANOV: Yeah, I think
that, to your question
around replayability,
there's kind of, I think,
three things that need
to happen and align
in a certain way, which
is hardware, software,
and content, right?
So if it becomes the barrier to
experiencing VR is a lot lower,
then replayability is not
really that much of an issue,
because you can just pick
this thing up, and it's cheap,
and it's easy, right?
And I think to follow on with
this, one interesting stat
that I guess you guys know
is that Goldman Sachs says
by 2025, VR will become
an $80 billion industry,
taking over TV.
That's interesting.
So be that as it may,
what do you think
are the key steps that need
to happen in order for VR
to go mainstream,
whatever that means?
KAY MESEBERG: I think if you
look back on smartphone market,
I mean, today you
have a phenomenon
that people say they
talked to someone,
but you don't know how.
I mean, did they call them?
Did they write a
WhatsApp, whatever?
You know, you don't know.
They just say that they are
in communication with someone.
And I think VR should be, and
AR should be, at the same level,
more or less, that
it's used intuitively.
Like, OK, it's there.
It's something.
And I do a call with my
friends in the states in 360,
and I see where they are, and
we can share the environment
and stuff like that.
So all this, I think, will come.
But you know, I think this
will be more or less the kind
of level where it will arrive.
BRADLEY CROOKS:
Yeah, I mean, I think
there's an interesting
kind of adoption
curve with any new technology,
that it has to become sort of--
it has to be
accessible to people
and sort of be something that
people are familiar with.
And obviously, as a
younger generation grows up
with that tech, they'll
probably be more willing to kind
of put headsets on and so on.
But again, I think
it just comes down
to what are the
applications going to be?
And I think you'll
probably begin
to see VR finding
different areas which
it's really good at.
So I think it has
lots of applications
for business to
business and training
and that type of thing.
I think there'll be a lot more
installation-based VR coming up
in the next couple of years.
You know, you'll see
it at theme parks.
You'll see it in malls
and things like that.
And I think that, again, will
kind of give the general public
much more exposure to it.
And that's a good way for
them getting involved,
because it's not them
doing that at home
and losing their
headset or whatever.
GREG IVANOV: Great.
Awesome.
OK, I think we're
all out of time.
So thank you so much for
joining and discussing.
Super interesting.
So yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]